(saw buzzing)
(mysterious music)
- [Climber] Yeah, go for it.
- Whoo!
- [Narrator] Mankind and the elements.
For some, it's an uncomfortable bond.
- [Woman] Good job.
- [Narrator] For others,
when weather strikes,
inspiration begins.
- There are so many people in life,
they forget to dream because
they're afraid to fail.
- [Narrator] These are the
people who challenge nature,
seek out its limits, reveal its secrets,
and embrace its awesome power.
In this episode, we'll meet two
pilots who circled the globe
by the power of the sun.
Climbers unafraid to
leap into nature's abyss.
And a man who turns high altitude snowfall
into giant works of art.
These pioneers of the
great outdoors ahead,
on That's Amazing.
(mysterious music)
- There are so many people in life,
they forget to dream
because they're afraid of
going out of their comfort zone.
- [Narrator] 13 years
ago, two enterprising pilots
shared a dream to achieve the impossible.
Their goal? To build the
first solar-powered plane
to fly around the world,
ushering in an aviation future
free of fossil fuels and pollution.
- Our goal is simply the
most way that is feasible.
- Tango, X-ray.
- [Narrator] Their plan was ambitious;
to cross the globe in 17 legs
over the course of a year,
logging 25,000 miles.
Taking turns in the cockpit,
co-pilots Bertrand Piccard
and André Borschberg,
knew that they would face
technical and operational challenges.
- [Engineer] We have to go back.
- [Narrator] While battling
weather and the elements.
- It has been really a difficult moment.
- [Narrator] In an unprecedented bid
for adventure and glory.
(dramatic music)
- When I was a child,
all the people I knew
were explorers,
adventurers, and astronauts.
- You know when I was a boy
I read a lot of books about
the pilots who opened the lines,
basically discovered the
worlds through airplanes.
- [Television Voice] He's
determined to succeed this time.
- [Bertrand] My grandfather
was the first man
in the stratosphere, inventing
the pressurized capsule.
Then my father made the deepest dive ever
touching the bottom of the Mariana Trench,
the deepest spot on Earth,
and showing that the deepest
trenches in the oceans
had to be protected.
- And I was fascinating
by the people who tried
something new, something different.
- I thought exploration
was the only way to live.
I flew nonstop around
the world in a balloon.
We burned almost four tons of propane gas.
It was pollution.
And I was thinking, “How
can I do it with no fuel?”
And this is how the dream
of Solar Impulse started.
Flying a solar-powered airplane
that produces its own
electricity with the sun,
store the electricity in batteries,
so you can fly through the night,
fly to the next sunrise forever.
- And when I made Bertrand 13 years ago,
I immediately had the impression
that my life was crossing
something extremely important.
- I found that André was the
was the missing part of me
and I was the mission part of him.
He's the engineer, entrepreneur, jet fighter pilot.
I'm a medical doctor, I'm an explorer,
so I asked him if he would agree to
partner with me to do it,
and he accepted immediately.
Together, we could be
the complete human being.
It's a very difficult airplane to fly,
maybe the most difficult
airplane in the world to fly
because of its huge wingspan,
very lightweight, and
sensitivity to turbulence.
So this you have to master completely.
- So at the beginning you
would just over-control it;
it's a disaster.
Using the simulator allowed us really to
get the feeling about the
personality of this airplane,
to know how to handle it.
- And I had the clearance from the tower.
- [Tower Control] You
are clear to proceed.
- And I could put full throttle, no noise
from the engines, and
the plane taking off.
And then just looking to stay in the air
as long as I can, no limit.
(light, uplifting music)
When we travel it takes three days
to fly where other people
would fly with a jet plane
in eight hours.
But you know that you
can stay there forever.
And what is magical is to look at the sun,
to look at the propellers on both side,
to see them turning without
noise and without pollution,
and to think, I'm in a
film of science fiction.
It cannot be true, but it is true.
So as soon as André can put full power
on the four electrical engines,
the around-the-world will start.
And I repeat, always, it's an attempt.
The around-the-world with Solar Impulse II
started in March 2015.
André and I, we took turns in the cockpit.
(light, pensive music)
Price Albert is next to me,
and he will give the official go,
and then the adventure
will start my friend.
- It's a great pleasure
to wish you all the best
for this fantastic
crossing of the Pacific,
so you are clear to proceed
with the takeoff procedures.
(people clapping)
- As soon as I took her from Japan,
one important equipment failed
and immediately the engineers told me
that I had to return to Japan to fix it.
But I looked at it completely differently,
that it was the first
time that the weather
was improving over the Pacific.
(mysterious pensive music)
- I would say we have to go back
as we have the choice.
- The engineers never understood that,
they never understood why
I was taking this risk.
Some of them wanted to resign immediately
and I decided to continue.
(mysterious, pensive music)
- There's only so much
we can do to support you
from here from the ground.
You will be on your own.
- It has been really a difficult moment,
do we go, we don't go,
but the weather is good,
the plane flies well, it's worth trying.
I did meditation; I couldn't sleep;
and slowly, at sunrise, I
could throw this emotion
overboard, and I could go back
to what I've been dreaming about
to enjoy these days I was
over the Pacific Ocean.
- I don't know how many
records we were setting
in this flight, and it's
the most difficult flight
of the whole journey around the world
that we succeeded.
(mysterious, pensive music)
(people clapping)
- [Bertrand] Inspiration is not
only when you are successful
and you raise the flag of victory.
It's through all these moments
where you have the
impression to lose control.
- The Solar Impulse II
mission started in Abu Dhabi
with many stopovers.
Across Asia first, over the Pacific,
across the United States,
over the Atlantic, across
the Mediterranean Sea,
all to get back here in the Middle East.
- I crossed the finish
line over Abu Dhabi,
and I had one hour and a half in the air
waiting before landing.
I could be in the full
emotion of the success,
but still in the full
emotion of the adventure.
And at that moment I thought
everything is possible.
Everything is possible.
Why don't we dream more?
Why don't we try more?
- [Woman] Beautiful! Whoo hoo!
- And few hours ago I had to
open the door of the cockpit,
I had to land.
And this flight around
the world became memories.
(audience applauding)
- What we did here was
really pioneering work,
and that's the slowly is understanding
the potential of these technologies.
In 10 years, we will
use electric airplanes.
Maybe not solar, this will take more time,
but certainly electric.
- If you have an impossible goal,
the people who are going to
support you are pioneers.
(light, peaceful music)
(mysterious music)
- [Simon] Making drawings on
land, on quite a large scale,
is something people have been
doing for thousands of years.
(mysterious music)
I'm Simon Beck, and I make
drawings in the snow.
(light, peaceful music)
It started as a bit of fun.
I started doing it as an easy alternative
to hiking up a mountain
when I wanted some exercise
and didn't feel quite energetic enough
to hike up a mountain.
It's a very temper and
unpredictable thing.
You're very much at the
mercy of the weather,
and really weather forecast.
And the best results
are obtained by waiting
until conditions are right
and try and finish it in one day.
So what you're looking for is
a fine, solid day forecast for tomorrow,
and a not-too-bad-day forecast for today.
So you tend to make it today
in the hope of getting
a photograph tomorrow.
We might just about
get it done by sundown,
so fingers crossed
we'll get a good result.
(rhythmic, determined music)
A ballpark estimate of footsteps,
about 5,000 steps in an hour.
Between one and two per second.
So a big drawing, two hours measuring,
eight hours work, you're
looking at 40,000 steps.
(light, peaceful music)
You start with a drawing
on a piece of paper,
or else a drawing in your mind.
Just treating it a bit like an orienteering map,
you're just going a certain
distance in a certain direction
determining distances by counting paces.
It's a very physical exercise.
It's equivalent to a long day's walking
in the hills when you make
one of these big drawings,
it's beyond what most
people would be able to do
in one day.
It's quite a task.
(light, peaceful music)
I often get asked to compare it with
making drawings on beaches on the sand.
Fear thought to the snow is
is that there's not a time limit,
it's not that sort of game
of when the tide comes in.
The great drawback of course,
is you can't walk on it
without making a mark.
The ideal snow is about so deep
and really soft and powdery,
with a really firm surface underneath it.
That means you can walk
through it quite easily
and you can walk all day
without getting too tired.
You're never quite sure
how it's gonna look,
so there's always a bit
of sort of fingers crossed
and when actually you
finally see it from above
for the first time.
(light, peaceful music)
At the moment I'm just about
the only person in the world
doing anything like it.
(light, peaceful music)
- [Engineer] To be able
to be doing science
while you're out there on a surfboard,
it's just such a fleeting moment,
it's incredible to
actually be able to do it.
(slow rock music)
- [Inventor] Smartfin is a surfboard fin.
You clip it on the bottom of your board,
you go out for your surf session.
It has technology that measures ocean pH,
salinity, ocean temperature,
and very detailed wave characteristics,
so there'll be an enormous amount of data.
The reason these parameters are important
is because they are shifting directly
as a result of climate change.
We have detailed information
about the deep ocean,
but very limited accurate
information about the near shore.
Satellites can't be
really accurate with data
in that narrow zone.
And the other way is ocean buoys,
and they're just not
deployed at the coast.
Bingo, Smartfin can fill that gap.
- Collecting oceanic data
is a very time-consuming,
expensive process.
This is like, you just
need to know how to surf.
The data moves from your fin to your phone
and then from your phone
is goes up to our servers
where everything is processed.
- So we've got a test tank set up now.
As a scientist it's pretty
exciting to be able to get data
over these different
time and space scales.
The fact that you can go out and surf
and contribute to understanding
what's actually happening
out there is incredible.
- Surfers are very influential,
and care deeply about the environment
and want to be talking about it.
So Smartfin is just a tool to do that
in a more concrete way.
(water trickling)
- [Researcher] Every place
in the world sounds unique.
These soundscapes tell us
a story about that place.
They tell us the ways
in which global warming
is beginning to change
the natural soundscape.
(tense string music)
Just before the sun rises at first light
is the dawn chorus.
The birds beginning to sing,
and the insects and the amphibians,
and that's the time of
day to go out and listen.
I'm a soundscape ecologist, I
record animals for a living.
This is Sugarloaf State Park.
Every Spring I can probably
be found there once a week
recording in the same spot,
using the same kind of equipment,
so that I can repeat these
recordings over and over again
and compare them.
And I have quite a archive
of material which shows,
over time, this habitat has
been changing pretty radically
as a result of global warming
and the California drought.
(birds singing)
The first recording made in 2004
shows a very robust habitat
with a signature of a stream.
In 2014, things were changing radically,
it was already the second
year of a major drought
in California.
And in 2015, we had what
I call a Silent Spring.
The question arises, what is it that
these soundscapes are telling us,
these biophanies are telling us?
My guess is that global warming
is playing a role in this
because Spring is coming two weeks earlier
than it normally does,
certainly than when it did 10 years ago.
That's one of the things that is so unique
about my library is we can
go back to these places
and we can compare currently
what they sound like with
what they sounded like
20, 30, 40 years ago.
Over 50% of my collection
comes from habitats
that are so radically altered,
they are either altogether silent
or can no longer be heard
in their original form.
Here's an example from Costa Rica.
(birds and wildlife singing)
That's before logging, this is after.
(few birds chirping)
Same spot.
This is a coral reef, Vanua Levu in Fiji.
Part of it is dying and
part of it is still living,
here's what the living part sounds like:
(water lapping)
Here's what the dying part sounds like:
Hardly any fish sounds.
We really don't know what
this means in the long run.
In the short run, we're beginning
to lose these soundscapes
because the habitats are just
changing so radically
00:19:26,036 --> 00:19:29,675
and we're partly to blame for that.
When I first began to
record almost 50 years ago,
I would go out into the
field and just put on
a pair of earphones and sit and listen
because it made me feel good.
It made me aware of the
living world around me,
and so I wanted to do anything
that does that for me.
(swelling pensive music)
(mysterious music)
- [Swimmer] Everyone says that I'm mad.
And they ask me that question
what draws me to the ice.
And what amazes me is
how many people follow.
- [Narrator] High in the
mountains of southern Africa
there are 15 fearless swimmers competing
in one of the most extreme races on Earth.
With no wetsuits, no protection,
they must swim a single kilometer
in water cold enough to kill them.
They call it a race, but
most would call it insanity.
As founder Ram Barkai will tell you,
the members of the International
Ice Swimming Association
don't just battle to the finish,
they're fighting to stay alive.
(mysterious music)
(saw buzzing)
- [Ram] Swimming cold water
has become my passion.
Okay, we need another task
force for these ones, hey?
The ice, was the icing on the cake.
I find the ice extreme.
I'm attracted to extreme challenges.
No doubt swimming in ice
is a dangerous sport.
- [Spectators] Go Ram, Go Ram!
- [Ram] It's not adrenaline junky,
polar bear type of experience,
you actually have to swim
one kilometer extremely fast
in water under five degrees
in just Speedo, goggles, and a cap.
these are the rules.
I founded the International
Ice Swimming Association.
I'd love it to become
a proper international
recognized sport.
- It's a double hit physiologically,
it's an ice swim, which is challenging,
and you're at altitude.
Most of you have not
been at altitude before.
- [Ram] I mean we're in Africa,
in the mountain of
Lesotho, and we found ice,
and we have a International
South African ice championship.
- Nowhere in Southern
Africa you gonna find
water five degrees or
below except for here.
- [Ram] Last year, we had
about 13 national championship
like this.
We have now swimmers in 28
countries around the world.
- We're doing an ice swim in Africa,
which is a bit ridiculous
if you ask anyone.
We also think it's ridiculous.
- It's a massive mental
challenge to get in that water
and to perform physically for
an extended period of time.
You keep going, takes a lot of mind power
and that's what I love, I
love pushing the boundaries
in these conditions.
(intense, pensive music)
- [Ram] It's not a sport where
you have to be lean, mean,
and beautiful to win.
You have to have around 20% body fat.
You have to be fit, you have to train
so your body and your mind know
how to deal with the shock.
Panic is the number one killer.
(water lapping)
- Initially, you can't tell
if the water is very hot
or very cold, it almost burns.
The first three minutes is painful,
and then you sort of settle
in and everything goes numb.
- The body temperature starts to drop.
Getting into this water poses
the hazard off hypothermia
to the athlete.
- [Ram] It causes havoc in your body,
to your blood pressure, to
your heart rate, to your
oxygen, to your brain.
- [Woman In Black Coat]
There's only one thing
that goes through your mind, breathe.
The ice takes your breath away,
and if you don't control it you can get
into a world of trouble.
- [Ram] The average time in
the water is 15 to 20 minutes,
which is still safe.
It's a hugely mental sport.
For me, it's mind over matter.
- It's not you racing
against someone else,
it's about you against
the ice and the cold,
and basically competing
against your own mind.
- This cold starts to affect the function
of the nervous system,
and so confusion, and
delirium sometimes happens,
the athletes can start to hallucinate
or they could have amnesia.
- If you feel dizzy and disorientated,
you should get out.
It's such a hard decision to make,
you're so close to the finish.
(quiet, intense music)
(spectators applauding and cheering)
- [Ram] As you come out of the water,
the brain starts releasing
blood from the core.
That process is what we
call the after drop.
In 10 minutes and suddenly
your core body temperature
can drop from 34 to 30,
and that causes a havoc.
If you haven't been there,
it's a scary experience.
- [Medical Worker] There you go, good job.
- Can you cover my legs?
- [Ram] We have a proper ICU,
doctors and recovery unit
to make sure that no one goes over edge.
It's literally like going
up the roller coaster,
you know, that feeling, slowly, slowly, slowly,
and suddenly, you get there.
When you get there, you
see people eyes go like.
We call it the Devil's look.
They know everything that's going on,
they hear everything,
they just can't respond.
You are in like a massive,
sort of tunnel vision,
focused on hanging in there.
- [Worker] You want some more chocolate?
- Feel the life going back into me.
I don't know if that's
a good thing though.
'Cause it's all a cough.
- I'm starting to turn the corner,
so I'm feeling better.
But life, and I wanna live.
- After the dust has settled
you feel like a champion.
- [Ram] Before they start swimming,
everyone ask himself, why am I doing this?
What am I trying to prove to myself?
Guys, well done to all of you.
I know it wasn't easy,
and I know that not everyone finished.
I think it's part of the process.
(swimmers cheering)
Then after I finish I can't wait
for the next adventure.
And I'm high for days.
My big dream is to get into
the winter Olympic Games
as a sport, it would be my legacy.
The beauty of what we're
doing here today is
to show that if there is
a will, there's a way.
(uplifting music)
(light, playful music)
- [Professor] I was the
snowflake consultant
on the movie Frozen.
They wanted to get all
the snowflakes right
and so they asked me how they grow,
and I was very pleased
when the movie came out
they all looked like little snowflakes,
none of them were eight-sided,
they were all six-sided,
and so, good job.
My name is Ken Libbrecht, and
I'm a professor of Physics
here at CalTech, and I
also grow snowflakes.
Well I got into physics very early,
I've been doing that most of my life.
Maybe about 20 years ago
I just got interested
in how crystals grow, and
that sort of led me to ice,
and to snowflakes.
We still don't exactly understand
why they look like they do
so it's kind fun to think about.
To make a snowflake in the
lab you start with water
and water vapor, you
gotta get it really cold.
And basically start a crystal growing,
and I'll kind of blow
moist air down onto it,
and it just absorbs
water vapor from the air
and starts to grow, and I can
do this on a piece of glass
and so just watch it grow.
I'm the only one that makes
snowflakes like this in the lab.
When you start to look really carefully
at how a snowflake works,
you find you don't understand it
and there's a lot going on.
You dig deeper there's
more and more stuff,
and it's really very
interesting to me anyway.
I love to go out and hunt for snowflakes
because these beautiful
works of art are just falling
all over, and you pick a few of them up
and photograph them, and the rest of them
you just trample on.
At the end of the day,
I'm trying to understand
how atoms and molecules fit
together to form crystals,
and by studying snowflakes
slowly you figure things out
that are, that are useful.
One snowflake at a time.
(chuckling)
(intense music)
- [Man] In my career I've
never met a single person
with his passion, ever.
And there's not even a close second.
- I get bloody, I put my body
into the capture, the hunt.
- [Man] The guy will go anywhere,
climb any mountain to
catch a fish in a stream.
He's doin' basically
the work of a biologist,
just as sort of a volunteer.
- [Steve] Science is important
because it's gonna help us
protect more populations
of these fish that are
some are only in one creek,
some are in one river.
It may be just another trout,
but it's a special trout, and
they're all special to me.
Already been through
Mar's collection ditch,
look at this baby right here.
Look at that sucker.
My name is Steve MacMillan,
trout enthusiast.
It is truly my goal to catch a fish
at every stream in Nevada.
There's over 600, I've been
workin' on this for years.
I'm a little over halfway there.
(light, playful music)
Very few people understand
the Nevada that I see.
- [Chris] When most
people think of Nevada,
a general picture comes into
mind of hot, dry, desert.
We're the most mountainous
state in the U.S.
In these mountains, we've
got a number of streams
that are primarily fed
with snow mountain runoff.
- [Steve] Nevada is actually
home of some of the most
diverse native species of trout on Earth.
It's definitely a passion;
it's definitely a obsession.
It's both, and there's
probably four other words
they haven't invented yet to describe
what I think about this fishing
and what it does to me.
- [Interviewer] Steve MacMillan,
what's the first impression
you get when you meet him?
- Nice.
- That looks like a
brookie there.
- Yeah it does.
- [Chris] It's almost
difficult to understand him
on the phone because he's
so excited about fish
and he talks so fast.
The one word to sum up Steve is passion.
- I work in the big city, work long hours,
I take a lotta work home with me,
I have a lot of stress at work.
In fact on weekends I
find myself in these hills
walkin' long mountain
trails to go up there and
try and catch a fish.
I feel like I own the place,
and many times I do own the place.
- About four or five years ago
was the Nevada Native Slam program.
A challenge to anglers in Nevada to catch
every native species, that
includes Lahontan Cutthroat,
the Bonneville Cutthroat,
Yellowstone Cutthroat,
Red Bands, Bull Trout,
and Mountain Whitefish.
- [Steve] So I began trekkin' the state
to catch these six species.
- [Chris] It's not easy.
You need to travel great lengths to catch
some of these species of fish
and they're in extremely
remote, rugged locations,
well Steve did it in
two and a half months.
- For me to be the first to achieve it,
it was very humbling.
The last fish was
probably, for most people,
the easiest one to catch, but for me,
I drove almost 3,000 miles
over 5 trips to catch it,
and when I caught that thing it was like
winning the Super Bowl.
(fast, playful music)
My fishing technique is
called ultralight spinning.
I'm using small weight lines,
usually two to four pound test,
I'm using a very small pole, small reel.
I can tell you that I go fishing,
I don't always go catching.
I'm learning every time I go out.
23 years ago, some of these places,
I coulda never caught fish, I never did,
and I've learned how to be
more patient with the fish,
I've learned to be more subtle,
I've learned to read what time to fish,
morning, evening.
I do watch moon phases,
it does affect the fishing
and, for me, it's basically
finding that spot,
knowing they're there,
watching and observing
instead of just being in a rush.
I practice a technique I've named CPR;
capture, photograph, release.
Here we go.
I think that's a good shot for posterity.
- [Chris] He documents
everything that happens that day
and he gets stream
temperature, air temperature,
lengths and weights of
fish and pictures of that
and he'll prepare a
report and send it to us.
He'll be out at a stream
that we haven't been to
in 50, 60 years
and he'll grab fin clips for us,
and that fin sample is
used for genetic analysis
to determine if that
population is genetically pure
or hybridized.
He has found species of fish in places
that we had no idea about.
So he's doin' the work of a biologist
just as sort of a volunteer.
(dramatic, swelling music)
- [Steve] The final icing on the cake
is taking that fish, give
him a kiss on the forehead,
putting it back in the
water and watch it swim off,
and thanking the fish
for being kind enough
to give me a chance to document its life
without killing it.
(mysterious music)
- You know, drought,
specifically in a state
as dry as Nevada, can be very problematic.
We're seein’, you know, the wetted length
of a number of our streams
decreasing dramatically.
- It's recording what I
think is a disappearing
part of our heritage.
These trout are disappearing
due to global warming,
efforts of mankind,
I believe that in my lifetime,
half these places I've
caught fish will be gone.
As a kid I had a very
large interest in biology,
so it's kinda the school child biologist
coming through as an adult.
It doesn't pay for itself,
hundreds of miles of gas,
sometimes thousands of miles in a weekend
to catch a fish, but to
me, that's what drives me.
The rewards of having biologists
and people that are enthusiasts contact me
and say, "I saw your
story, I've read about ya."
that makes me feel like a superstar,
and all I am is, is just
a guy going fishing,
and I know my story is
pretty lame to most people,
but to me it is the,
it's the top of the hill.
It's the glory.
(light, playful music)
(slow, peaceful music)
- [Narrator] The largest
insect migration in the world
ends each year in Michoacán, Mexico.
Cold winters are deadly to
these beautiful butterflies,
so when the chill of winter
descends on the northern half
of their range across the
United States and Canada,
they take flight en masse,
in search of a warmer winter home.
(light, peaceful music)
An estimated 100 million
Monarch pass the cold months
of the winter hibernation period
in the towering trees of
this beautifully protected
nature reserve in western Mexico.
On their incredible journey,
the butterflies travel an
average of 2,500 miles,
relying on air currents and thermal drafts
to carry them long distances.
The Monarch is the only butterfly known
to migrate the same way that birds do.
At night, when the temperature drops,
they cluster together in tight groups
to conserve heat and energy.
This survival tactic
produces some of the most
stunning formations
across the insect world.
(rhythmic, intense music)
- [Narrator] While canyoneering
is a brand new sport,
it starts with an old
school leap of faith.
Its participants hold their breath
as they repel down
seemingly bottomless canyons
formed by centuries of wind and water,
through oncoming waterfalls,
around blind turns,
and dangling over cliffs,
the sports pioneers
take on natural wonders
the rest of us would never dare.
Kitt Turner is one of those pioneers.
He and his team are about
to enter Canada's Box Canyon
for the first time,
a place that will make their knees quake.
- [Kitt] I got started
running canyons in Hawaii.
I started rock climbing and
eventually made the progression
into canyoneering.
Jenna's my girlfriend,
she's a Hawaii girl,
born and raised.
We've been dating now
for almost two years.
We met climbing.
- Kitt always pushes me
to go outside my comfort level a lot.
(mysterious music)
- [Kitt] When you're
talking about canyoneering,
the process of descending a canyon,
you have to decide how much
rope you wanna bring along,
you wanna decide if the rock
quality is gonna be good enough
to set up anchors for the repels.
You also have to find a good crew
that is good under pressure.
- You're just dealing with
lots of complexities of nature,
rocks, waterfall, it's just
constant problem solving
using your brain, using your body.
- [Kitt] Canyons are very fickle,
and they're very weather-dependent.
Conditions in a canyon
can change from one day
to the next, from one season to the next.
(dramatic music)
For this particular canyon, Box Canyon,
you have to cross the Squamish River.
- [Jenna] Kayaking across
the river, it was an ordeal
because you just really have
to paddle your heart out
just to cut across that current,
and then you have to make
a sharp U-turn into this
little tiny beachfront.
- [Kitt] So once you cross the river,
there's a mosquito-infested hike
into the bottom of the Box Canyon stream.
And then you hike upstream for awhile
before you get to the
technical part of the canyon
which involves rope.
- [Jenna] The first thought
was, “Is this man made?”
This is not real.
It looks like a Disneyland ride.
- One, two, three.
(dramatic music)
- [Kitt] Box Canyon is
considered a Class C canyon.
(water rushing)
Most of the repels, if not all the repels,
you're going straight
through the water course,
which is straight through the waterfall,
and you're getting pounded by the water,
it's hitting you in your face.
You're slipping, you're
sliding all over the place.
- [Jenna] My favorite thing
about dropping into a canyon
is the rush of getting over the edge.
- This is my passion, man,
I don't get more pumped
than when I'm in a canyon.
- [Kitt] It kinda adds
that element of excitement
where you can't see where
you're gonna end up.
- [Jenna] When you're on
the edge of an adventure,
when you feel like I could
die doing this right now
but I can't back down, and then you do it,
it's like the most amazing feeling.
- Whoo, yeah!
I don't get the people that are like,
why would you do that?
I'm just like, “Why not?”
(chuckling)
If you don't get it, you don't get it.
- [Kitt] For someone who's looking
at doing what we did, which
is dropping everything
and pursuing your dreams,
I would say that it's
definitely a leap of faith,
and maybe you crash and burn.
But the highs are
incredible and you're never
gonna get those amazing
moments and see if you
can really achieve your
dreams if you don't try.
(dramatic, inspirational music)
(loud bing)